Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today I am going to explain a short sci-fi
drama film called “High Maintenance.”
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
At the beginning of the movie, we are introduced
to a man and his wife namely; Paul and Jane.
The two are dining on a fine evening in their
house.
The table is sparsely lit with candle light
and the husband and wife are eating in silence.
The only noise that can be heard is the tinkling
of cutlery as they cut their food.
Jane awkwardly looks at Paul and tries to
say something but decides against it.
Throughout the dinner, she glances at him
several times trying to start any kind of
conversation to end the awkwardness.
Paul, on the other hand, hardly acknowledges
her.
His entire focus is on his food that he seems
to be enjoying greatly.
Having had enough of acting like strangers,
Jane wipes her hand and gets up.
She picks up the bottle of wine on the table
and approaches her husband.
Jane hopes to stir up a conversation again
but as she tries to pour him the alcohol,
he covers his glass with his palm.
Jane is taken aback but she doesn’t react.
Paul talks for the first time and claims that
he doesn’t want to drink.
To sound a little less harsh he calls her
dear but it does not make Jane feel any better.
She simply sits back down in her seat and
looks visibly hurt by her husband’s lack
of concern.
She talks for the first time and reveals that
it is their wedding anniversary, urging him
to let go and drink on the occasion.
Hearing this, Paul stops eating and looks
her dead in the eyes, clearly annoyed by all
the talking when he could be enjoying his
meal in silence.
He simply says that he cannot drink because
he has to work the next day.
When the husband doesn’t even bother to
explain further, Jane sighs of annoyance.
To make up for him not drinking, she chugs
down an entire glass of wine while not breaking
eye contact with him.
She puts the glass down with a sigh, proud
of herself for rebelling.
Still, Paul doesn’t utter a word to comment
on the fact, so she fills up the glass again.
Before she can chug down the rest of it, Paul
states that the asparagus that she made for
dinner is very tender.
In a last attempt to stir up a spicy conversation,
Jane claims that people say asparagus is an
aphrodisiac; a food that increases sexual
desire and pleasure.
The wife is hoping for an interesting reply
from him but is left disappointed when he
asks her where she heard that from.
She stammers and claims that she heard it
from some people.
Jane appears to have gotten nervous after
the question.
She quickly puts food in her mouth to keep
from talking but it doesn’t go unnoticed
by the husband.
Paul doesn’t question her further and they
settle back to their old routine.
Only a few seconds later, he calls her dear
and asks her about her day.
This is the last straw for Jane.
When the anger gets the best of her, she gets
up and throws her just filled glass of wine
to Paul’s face.
Having enough of his nonchalant and uptight
behavior, she asks him to shut up and have
a drink for once.
She also comments that he is only a mere computer
analyst and not a surgeon so nothing is going
to change if he drinks a glass of wine for
a special occasion.
Throughout her screaming, Paul remains calm
and composed.
The fact that his face is covered in wine
doesn’t seem to bother him as much.
Jane again asks him to relax for once in his
life.
The husband ignores her entirely and brings
out his case of cigarettes to have a smoke.
An already furious Jane glows red in anger
after seeing him put a cigarette to his mouth.
She whispers to him to not dare smoke but
it doesn’t stop the husband.
He lights the cigarette up and takes a big
puff making Jane get up and snatch the cigarette
away from his lips.
She claims that the house is hers, so he will
have to do what she wants.
She presses the cigarette on an ashtray but
turns around to see that Paul has lit another
one.
The husband waits for another glass of wine
to his face but it never comes.
To his utmost surprise, Jane composes herself
and sits down in her seat.
She sarcastically encourages him to keep going,
stating that passive smoke is exactly what
she wanted as her anniversary gift.
Paul doesn’t answer so she keeps talking
to fill the silence.
Jane claims that she only gets the privilege
of stilted conversations with her husband
on a normal day.
She ironically adds that if she is extremely
lucky she might get a short mechanical sexual
intercourse from him.
The insult hurts Paul’s feelings and he
finally shows a hint of emotion on his face.
He stares at her with teary eyes which brings
Jane back from her angered state.
She regretfully apologizes for saying that.
Moments later, she walks up to him and sits
on his lap trying to console him like a child.
She claims that she didn’t mean what she
said but Paul is not naive to believe her
words.
Jane hugs him and slowly slides her hands
down the back of his head.
One might think she is trying to seduce him,
but she turns off a switch on his neck.
Paul goes limp after that.
It is then revealed that he is actually a
robot that Jane has brought from a robotics
company that provides AI boyfriend services.
She sits back in her place, this time with
her feet on the dining table, and wishes her
former husband a happy anniversary.
A while later, she is on her laptop browsing
for a new husband on the robotic company’s
website.
After looking for some time, she finds the
one she likes; a man who is athletic and way
more interesting than the current one.
She calls the company and complains that she
is unsatisfied with the model of man she owns.
The operator apologizes for the inconvenience
and asks her what problems she is facing.
Jane claims that Paul lacks ambition and has
no sense of adventure, he is just too much
of a robot to be a good husband.
The operator claims that lack of ambition
is a common malfunction with the series of
robots that Paul belongs to.
She asks Jane the features she would like
her updated husband to be incorporated with.
Jane says that she wants a more athletic man
who either does rock climbing or is a masseuse.
She looks at a reference photo and asks for
a man with less beard and shorter blonde hair.
After providing all the information on what
she wants him to look like, Jane waits for
the delivery that will happen the same night.
Only some hours later, someone knows on her
door.
She peeks through the looking hole to make
sure it is the people she was waiting for.
She opens it to find a woman from the robotics
company standing outside.
Seconds later, she is joined by another woman
with the box of her preferred husband.
The workers take the new man out of the plastic
bag and place him on his seat at the dining
table.
Jane is left speechless after seeing his handsome
face, although he looks identical to the previous
Paul, only a bit blonder.
They put the old one in a stretcher and take
him out.
However, Jane cannot help but stop them to
wish her former husband goodbye for the last
time.
She runs to him and gently kisses him on the
lips, regretful that she has to let him go,
but happy that she has an upgraded husband
now.
Following that, she pulls out the wedding
ring from his finger and lets the worker take
him away.
She then brings the ring inside and makes
her new husband wear it.
The upgraded version of Paul is already fitted
with his old memories so Jane will not have
to bother to introduce herself and take their
relationship from the start.
She simply turns his switch on and continues
having dinner as she did with the former Paul.
The upgraded Paul wakes up and eats his first
bite of food.
Jane waits for him to say something but he
doesn’t.
However, she doesn’t appear to be disappointed.
She offers him a glass of wine but like the
previous Paul, this one also declines and
claims that he has a big climb the next day.
Proving how similar he is to the not upgraded
version, he also comments that the asparagus
is very tender.
However, something shifts in the conversation
following that.
Jane starts to act submissive like the not
upgraded Paul did.
She affirms that the vegetable is in fact
good and doesn’t continue the conversation.
To spice up the conversation, the upgraded
Paul claims that asparagus is aphrodisiac.
He expects her to reply to his comment with
something interesting, but just like the previous
Paul, she asks him where he heard that from.
She calls him dear and doesn’t converse
much.
It is almost as if Paul is tired of her being
nonchalant to their wedding anniversary.
Paul gets up from his seat and walks towards
her.
Jane is nervous and confused as to what he
is about to do.
He takes her by surprise and starts to seductively
massage her shoulders.
As she melts in his touch, he asks her about
her day.
The last time he asked her the same question
ended up in him being showered with wine,
however, something has changed this time because
Jane is more nervous than angry.
She replies to his question, saying that she
went to the town to get some stuff for dinner
tonight.
Jane can hardly focus on what she is trying
to say as Paul touches her appealingly.
The stress she had from dealing with the older
one vanishes as she relaxes in his touch.
He urges her to continue, so she explains
how she went out for lunch with her friend
Anna.
As she speaks, she cannot stop smiling at
the thought of having such a wonderful husband
who gives her massages and is considerate
enough to ask her about her day.
She continues to talk and proudly says that
she treated herself for the anniversary.
One second, she is talking about her day and
the other, her expression changes and she
stops abruptly.
A click sound is heard from the back.
Paul doesn’t react to his wife going limp.
In contrast, he simply walks away.
When the camera pans to the back of Jane’s
head, we see that she also has a switch on
the back of her neck that Paul has just turned
off.
Only then, it is revealed that she is also
a robot.
The updated version of Paul was too advanced
for her, so he found her boring, similar to
what she thought of the former Paul.
This is the reason that all three of them
often repeated each other’s words and didn’t
realize it.
They were manufactured by the same company
which means that their primary behavior is
the same.
Paul simply sits on the couch with a lit cigarette
and a bottle of beer.
He puts his feet on top of the coffee table
and turns the TV on.
In the last scene, he stares into the television,
watching a football match.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thank You for watching.